in this video i'm going to show you five
of my favorite retro effects in adobe
after effects these are all retro
effects that will give your videos a
really cool
retro vintage look so let's get started
hey there my name is cameron with motion
science and i know there's a lot of
different effects out there and it can
be tough to decide which ones to use but
don't worry i've got you covered with
these really cool retro effects that can
help give your videos that old school
vibe so for our footage here i've got a
3d render of some cubes moving through
space that i got off a stock footage
site and the very first thing we do here
is i apply the curves effect and you can
see immediately how that looks what i'm
doing here is i'm lifting the shadows
and i'm also dropping the highlights so
i'm creating a
curve that looks just like we see here
next thing i'm doing is i'm applying
some hue and saturation
and all i'm doing there is i'm dropping
the master saturation by about 35
so that's without saturation that's with
just reducing it next thing i'm doing is
i'm adding some noise to this i like to
use a value typically between 5 and 15
it's not very often i go above 15 but
that's with and without next thing i'm
doing is i'm adding venetian blinds to
give it that scan line effect i'm just
setting this to a value of 10
adjusting the direction to 90 degrees
and making the width a value of 5. next
thing we're going to do is we're going
to blur the crap out of this image so
fastbox blur set the blur radius to
three iterations to three
repeat edge pixels is not ticked and you
can see there it's looking pretty bad
but we're gonna go ahead and sharpen
that up with our last effect here and
click sharpen and i've set this to a
value of 250 and let's go ahead and turn
off all the effects so without and with
quite a difference right so let's go
ahead and preview without and with and
you can see there it's got that really
old school retro vibe going on next
composition i like to use an effect
called uni analog this can be found
under rg universe stylize and it's right
here uni analog and what i love about
this effect we're going to turn it on
here is it's got that kind of old-school
crt feel to it and it comes with a lot
of really awesome presets we can see
here there's like attic tv
burning
camcorder detect is gonna be like a
black and white
look cop show
commercial break
a dither i mean the list goes on and on
and on we can also drop down here these
are the non-crt
formats
and lots of really cool presets in here
as well i can always get a really quick
look
just by applying some of these presets
here and just you know playing around
you can just get a lot of really
different looks very quickly
so you can see here in motion how this
footage now looks with the uni analog
filter applied i usually typically will
take a preset and then adjust some of
the values like we see here but this is
how i got this look next up we've got a
plug-in called signal i'm just going to
go ahead and apply this and immediately
you can see how this looks and i like to
just kind of play around with the
different settings up in here so signal
strength is a good one
cutoff filter is a good one as well
and then also playing around with the
different emulating vhs presets here
instruction button all that good stuff
and let's take a look at how this one
looks so there you go look at that that
is so so cool it's got that really
old-school kind of vhs retro vibe moving
on to our next example here again i'm
using another plug-in from red giant
this is an rg universe stylized av club
and this is an old-school one that i
absolutely go to
all the time again i like to take a
preset from this plug-in there's not as
many presets here but they're all unique
in their own right and
again i like to just apply the preset
and then go in and adjust
some of these settings in here for
example jitter is one that i'm going to
play around with that's that's causing
that kind of that bumpiness happening
here but you can see immediately a super
cool retro
look happening here and the last one i'm
going to show you is from one of my
favorite plug-in companies boris fx this
is sapphire and it is under effect
i believe sapphire stylize and we're
going to go to stv damage which we can
find right here what i absolutely love
about sapphire is that there are so many
awesome presets that come with their
different plugins
and you can see here 70s tv i think it's
the one that i'm going with right now a
cool tv distressed tv you can also click
the play button here and get a real-time
feedback once it loads into ram there of
how it's going to look so this is pretty
cool stuff occult tv some really
retro looking stuff there we've got a
vhs look to it surveillance camera
and you can see right here how this is
looking straight out of the box with a
preset from sapphire so let's take a
look at all five examples now laid out
side by side by side and you're gonna
see the difference here this first
example are the built-in effects from
after effects using hue saturation
venetian blinds and a few others next
we've got uni analog
really interesting look here
third is the plugin called signal fourth
is another
red giant plug-in called av club
and fifth is sapphire's tv damage
those are my five favorite effects
for getting a retro look out of after
effects i hope that you really enjoyed
this lesson on creating retro looks
inside of after effects please let me
know if you have any questions in the
comments i'd love to answer them for you
hit that like button if you enjoyed this
video and please subscribe to this
channel it helps other people find this
channel as well if you're looking to
upgrade your design skill set master the
other style and execute like a pro i
have a course called stylecraft that you
can check out at motionscience.tv you
can also learn more about this course by
clicking that link in the description
thanks for watching everyone my name is
cameron and this is motion science
[Music]
you